Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. The clothes we put on every day tell a story about who we are to the world and can have a major impact on our emotions and mood. So where does psychology fit into all of this and how does it help us solve some of the biggest challenges facing the fashion industry now and in the future? Our guest for this episode is Dr. Carolyn Mayer, a cognitive psychologist who created the Psychology of Fashion Department at the London College of Fashion at the University of Arts London, as well as an undergraduate program and two master's degree programs there. Dr. Mayor is currently a consultant for fashion brands and recently published a book called The Psychology of Fashion. Welcome, Dr. Mayor. Thank you very much, Caitlin. It's a pleasure to be here. Thank you. We're happy to have you. So how did you get into this field?
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。我们每天穿的衣服向世界讲述着关于我们是谁的故事，并可能对我们的情绪和心境产生重大影响。那么，心理学在这一切中扮演什么角色？它又如何帮助我们解决时尚产业目前及未来面临的一些最大挑战呢？本期节目的嘉宾是卡罗琳·梅耶博士，她是一位认知心理学家，在伦敦艺术大学伦敦时装学院创建了时尚心理学系，并设立了一个本科专业和两个硕士学位项目。梅耶博士目前担任时尚品牌的顾问，最近出版了一本名为《时尚心理学》的书。欢迎您，梅耶博士。非常感谢，凯特琳。很高兴来到这里。谢谢。我们很高兴邀请到您。那么，您是如何进入这个领域的呢？
I've always been interested in fashion and my first job was a window dresser or visual merchandiser as is known now. I did that for four years, absolutely loved it. And then I did several other creative jobs, making clothes for people, making clothes for myself, and so on. And then when I got into my 30s and I had three children, I decided it was time to get a degree. So I did my undergraduate degree in applied psychology and computing. Then I did a master's in research methods. And then I was very fortunate to be able to have a funded PhD studentship. So after my PhD, I really wanted to work in the applied field of psychology
我一直对时尚很感兴趣，我的第一份工作是橱窗陈列师，也就是现在所说的视觉营销师。我做了四年，非常热爱这份工作。后来我还做过其他几份创意工作，比如为别人做衣服、为自己做衣服等等。到了30多岁，有了三个孩子后，我决定是时候去拿个学位了。于是我攻读了应用心理学和计算机专业的本科学位。接着我读了研究方法的硕士学位。后来我很幸运地获得了一个有资助的博士生名额。所以博士毕业后，我非常想在心理学的应用领域工作。
because my PhD was so theoretical. And I worked for seven years in an ordinary psychology department as a senior lecturer and then became a professor. And then I was at a conference and I met some. somebody from London College of Fashion. And when I asked him if there were any psychologists there, he said there weren't and that I should come and do a paper there. And so I gave a paper at London College of Fashion on the importance of psychology for fashion.
因为我的博士研究太理论化了。我在一个普通的心理学系担任了七年高级讲师，后来成为了教授。有一次在参加会议时，我遇到了一位来自伦敦时装学院的人。当我问他那里是否有心理学家时，他说没有，并建议我去那里发表一篇论文。于是，我在伦敦时装学院发表了一篇关于心理学对时尚重要性的论文。
And I was invited back to discuss how I could bring psychology to the college. And that was back in 2011. I started working there in 2012 and developed a mind. master's courses and set up the department before I left in 2017. Wow. So you've had a lifelong interest in fashion and that became academic and now here you are having, have set up this program at the college. That's wonderful. Thank you. And you wrote in your book that there are very few psychologists in this field. So from your perspective, why is it important to have psychologists researching and working in the fashion industry?
后来我受邀回去讨论如何将心理学引入该学院。那是2011年的事了。我于2012年开始在那里工作，开发了硕士课程，并在2017年离开前建立了该系。哇。所以您对时尚有着终身的兴趣，后来将其学术化，现在您又在这里建立了这个项目。这太棒了。谢谢。您在书中写道，这个领域几乎没有心理学家。那么从您的角度来看，为什么让心理学家在时尚产业进行研究和工作很重要呢？
Well, the fashion industry is about people. It employs millions of worldwide and everyone wears clothes. Clothes are the closest thing to our bodies. They're our second skin. And psychologists can help with lots of the issues that are known to be caused by the fashion industry. So for example, the fashion industry has a poor reputation in terms of social responsibility. And now, coming to a head, and it's been around for decades actually, are the issues about sustainability. So the fashion industry, is one of the worst industries for damaging the environment. And psychologists can help with this.
嗯，时尚产业是关于人的产业。它在全球雇佣了数百万人，而且每个人都要穿衣服。衣服是我们身体最贴近的东西。它们是我们的第二层皮肤。心理学家可以帮助解决许多已知由时尚产业引起的问题。例如，时尚产业在社会责任方面声誉不佳。而现在，可持续发展的问题已经迫在眉睫，实际上这个问题已经存在几十年了。所以，时尚产业是破坏环境最严重的行业之一。而心理学家可以对此提供帮助。
They can help the consumers change their habits through developing behaviour change programs. They can also work with employers to help them create workplaces that provide better conditions for their staff. And they can also help in predicting demand so that there's far less waste when the items are made. So currently, fashion forecasters tend to work on intuition, gut feeling.
他们可以通过开发行为改变项目来帮助消费者改变习惯。他们还可以与雇主合作，帮助他们创造能为员工提供更好工作条件的职场环境。他们还可以帮助预测需求，从而在生产商品时减少浪费。目前，时尚预测者往往依靠直觉和预感来工作。
Sometimes they look at historical cycles. But psychologists are well trained in data analysis, and they will be able to predict fashion trends much better using data. And of course, there's the obvious way that psychologists can work in the fashion industry, and that's in consumer behavior. Consumers are becoming more and more demanding. They are wanting more than just to be satisfied. Customers now have fantastic opportunities for competition for searching online and in store.
有时他们会观察历史周期。但心理学家受过良好的数据分析训练，他们将能够利用数据更准确地预测时尚趋势。当然，心理学家在时尚产业中还有一种显而易见的工作方式，那就是消费者行为领域。消费者变得越来越挑剔。他们想要的不仅仅是满足。现在的顾客在网上和实体店搜索时拥有极好的竞争机会。
So the retail companies, fashion retail companies, have to give consumers a fantastic experience. And who better to help design a fantastic experience than psychologists? You just touched on some very interesting issues regarding overconsumption and regarding the environment. So you cited an alarming statistic in your book as well about that in the U.S., about an estimated 15 million people have a spending addiction. So we know that overconsumption is clearly an issue. How can people break the cycle and consume more responsibly? Well, it's a very difficult one because the way we shot becomes a habit and lots of
因此，零售公司，即时尚零售公司，必须为消费者提供绝佳的体验。而还有谁比心理学家更适合帮助设计这种绝佳体验呢？您刚才谈到了一些关于过度消费和环境的非常有趣的问题。您在书中也引用了一个令人震惊的统计数据，即在美国，估计有1500万人患有消费成瘾症。所以我们知道过度消费显然是一个问题。人们如何才能打破这种循环并更负责任地消费呢？嗯，这是一个非常困难的问题，因为我们的购物方式已经成为一种习惯，而且我们很多人
Lots of us go shopping as a social pleasure, as a leisure pursuit. And so shopping becomes part of what we do, part of our identity. And also, you know, we like novelty. We like fashion. We want to look nice and enhance ourselves. But people can also change their habits through structure, behavior change programs. So they can learn to identify what are the,
我们很多人把购物当作一种社交乐趣，一种休闲追求。因此，购物成了我们生活的一部分，成了我们身份的一部分。而且，你知道，我们喜欢新鲜感。我们喜欢时尚。我们想看起来漂亮并提升自己。但人们也可以通过结构化的行为改变项目来改变他们的习惯。所以他们可以学会识别什么是
habits? What are the triggers that encourage them to go out and buy more, more, more, more? And quite often they don't wear these items. And how can their habits be changed so that it's a win-win situation for them. So they have more money in their pockets to enjoy experiences rather than material objects. And they can also do good for the environment by consuming less and contributing less to the landfill problem. Is this something you're working on in your consulting work? Yes, yes. So I'm currently working across so many issues within the fashion industry.
习惯？是什么触发了他们去买、买、买、买？而且他们往往并不穿这些东西。如何改变他们的习惯，使之成为对他们双赢的局面？这样他们口袋里就有更多的钱去享受体验，而不是物质对象。他们还可以通过减少消费和减少对垃圾填埋问题的贡献来为环境做贡献。这是您在咨询工作中正在研究的事情吗？是的，是的。所以我目前正在处理时尚产业内的许多问题。
And it's just such an amazing opportunity to make a really important difference globally. So yes, changing people's habits. looking at the communication that we put out as a business, looking at how we communicate with our staff and with our customers. Yeah, so this is something that I've been doing as a consultant since 2017, understanding that, you know, the consumers are people and they have behavior and psychologists understand behavior. So as a cognitive psychologist, looking at all the cognitive processes,
这是一个在全球范围内产生真正重要影响的绝佳机会。所以是的，改变人们的习惯。审视我们作为企业发布的信息，审视我们如何与员工和客户沟通。是的，这是我自2017年以来作为顾问一直在做的事情，理解消费者是人，他们有行为，而心理学家了解行为。所以作为一名认知心理学家，审视所有的认知过程，
the way we think, the way we perceive, the way we understand the world and make sense of it, all these things, processes that we do as human beings. This is what psychologists can help the fashion industry. And to be honest, all industry learn more about. And you wrote a lot about the fast fashion, which we've touched on as well, the environmental impacts of this and the human impacts of it, how it's created environmental and human rights problems. And there has been some movement in a positive direction, some more awareness of this,
我们的思维方式、感知方式、理解世界并赋予其意义的方式，所有这些作为人类所做的过程。这就是心理学家可以帮助时尚产业的地方。老实说，所有行业都可以学到更多。您在书中写了很多关于快时尚的内容，我们也谈到了这一点，即它的环境影响和人类影响，它是如何造成环境和人权问题的。虽然在积极方向上有一些进展，也有了一些更多的意识，
but people are still suffering in sweatshops and landfills are still getting filled up with unused or unwanted clothing. What is needed to change this trend? Okay, first of all, I think it's quite important that this notion of fast fashion equals bad needs to be changed. So lots of items which are not considered fast fashion are made in exactly the same. factories under exactly the same conditions. The problem is not with fast fashion per se. The problem is with overproduction and over consumption. That ends up in the landfill sites.
但人们仍然在血汗工厂中受苦，垃圾填埋场仍然堆满了未穿过或不需要的衣服。需要什么来改变这种趋势？好吧，首先，我认为“快时尚等于坏”这个概念需要改变，这一点很重要。因为许多不被认为是快时尚的商品也是在完全相同的工厂、完全相同的条件下制造的。问题不在于快时尚本身。问题在于过度生产和过度消费。这最终导致了垃圾填埋场的问题。
There are problems with the working conditions, with abuse of the workers, with human rights, as you say. And these need to be addressed at the local level because the factories, are typically run by people in the local communities, and there is a lot of pressure on them to change, and hopefully they will. When the pressure turns into voting with our wallets, which is, I think we're beginning to see that.
工作条件、对工人的虐待、人权等方面存在问题，正如您所说。这些需要在地方层面解决，因为工厂通常由当地社区的人经营，他们面临着很大的改变压力，希望他们会改变。当压力转化为用钱包投票时，我认为我们已经开始看到这一点了。
People are buying less and being more mindful with what they buy, then the behavior of the factory owners and the retail companies will change accordingly. And the pressure is coming from consumers now. So you are seeing changes in the opposite direction where people are being more mindful about what they purchase and how much of it. Some pockets of the population, yes, for sure.
人们买得更少，对购买的东西更用心，那么工厂主和零售公司的行为就会相应改变。现在压力来自消费者。所以您正在看到相反方向的变化，人们对购买什么以及购买多少更加用心。部分人群确实是这样。
But there are still people who want to consume a lot simply because it's cheap. And in reality, they probably spend as much as they would on five or six very cheap items as they would if they bought one, more one expensive item or more expensive item that they would actually wear and it would potentially last longer and they would value it more. Do you think a solution is for people to purchase perhaps higher quality items?
但仍然有人因为便宜而想大量消费。实际上，他们花的钱可能和买一件更贵、他们真正会穿且可能更耐用、更珍惜的衣服所花的钱一样多。您认为解决办法是让人们购买质量更高的商品吗？
Sometimes that can mean more expensive items as opposed to those, you know, buying five T-shirts for the price of one nice shirt. Is that one way to alleviate the problem? Yes. I think I think that makes perfect sense because, you know, buying four. five of very similar items and four of them are unlikely to be worn is purely wasteful. And because they're cheap, they're probably not going to be sold or swapped or nobody is really going to want them secondhand anyway. So, yeah, I would definitely say buy less,
有时这意味着更昂贵的商品，而不是那种，你知道，花买一件好衬衫的钱去买五件T恤。这是缓解问题的一种方法吗？是的。我认为这非常有道理，因为，你知道，买四五件非常相似的商品，其中四件很可能不会穿，这纯粹是浪费。而且因为它们很便宜，它们可能不会被转卖或交换，反正也没人真的想要二手货。所以，是的，我绝对会说少买，
buy mindfully, enjoy the experience, but don't buy multiple items that you're not going to wear. And think about it at the point of sale. When are you going to wear this item or these items? Do you really want to buy it? And is it just going to hang in your wardrobe with the tag still on it until you decide you don't want it anymore and find out that nobody else does either, which is just so wasteful? So there does come a point in a life cycle of a piece of clothing item where you might want to give it away or to donate it or something of that nature. Is that a good solution to give away your clothes, give them to charity, give them to friends? Yeah, definitely. Anything that stops them going into landfill is good. Recycling, if the product can be recycled,
用心购买，享受体验，但不要购买多件你不会穿的商品。在销售点考虑一下。你什么时候会穿这件或这些商品？你真的想买吗？它是不是只会挂在你的衣柜里，标签还没摘，直到你决定不再想要它，却发现别人也不想要，这太浪费了？所以在一件衣服的生命周期中，确实会有一个时刻，你可能想把它送人、捐赠或做类似的事情。把衣服送人、捐给慈善机构、送给朋友是一个好的解决方案吗？是的，绝对是。任何阻止它们进入垃圾填埋场的事情都是好的。回收，如果产品可以回收，
then fantastic. Sometimes the recycling process does quite a lot of harm to the environment as well. Separating different fabrics, different textiles is difficult and not always possible. but anything is better than putting your unwanted items in the bin that would go to landfill. So swapping, renting clothes is becoming more and more popular, selling on a market, individuals selling their own clothes, it's also becoming popular. And lots of fashion brands, fast fashion I'm well aware of, I'm not sure that the higher end the fashion market does this, is accepting bags of recycle, well, clothes that you don't want, previously loved clothes, let's say, for recycling. And they might be used if they can be separated
那就太棒了。有时回收过程对环境的危害也很大。分离不同的面料、不同的纺织品很困难，并不总是可行的。但任何事情都比把你不需要的东西扔进垃圾桶送去填埋要好。所以交换、租借衣服正变得越来越流行，在市场上销售，个人出售自己的旧衣服，这也正变得流行。许多时尚品牌，我很清楚快时尚品牌，我不确定高端时尚市场是否这样做，正在接受回收袋，嗯，你不想要的衣服，以前喜欢的衣服，我们这么说吧，用于回收。如果它们能被分离出来，它们可能会被使用
out for recycling. Some are used for stuffing other fabrics, for rags. And then some are sent on to other countries. So there's some organizations that go around and buy. unwanted used clothing. But this can be problematic because the used clothes might end up actually frustrating the development of the fashion industry in developing markets. I want to turn now to mental health. And as you mentioned, clothing conveys a lot about a person. So what does, how does what we put on our bodies everyday influence our mental health?
用于回收。有些被用于填充其他织物，做抹布。还有一些被送到其他国家。所以有一些组织四处收集不需要的旧衣服。但这可能会有问题，因为旧衣服最终可能会阻碍发展中市场时尚产业的发展。现在我想转向心理健康。正如您提到的，服装传达了一个人的很多信息。那么，我们每天穿在身上的东西如何影响我们的心理健康呢？
Well, it's stressful for us if we don't feel comfortable in what we're wearing. If we're really worrying that it's appropriate or it's suitable or we don't feel confident in what we're wearing, it stresses us. And this means that we don't have the cognitive capacity to deal with a problem at hand. This is why lots of very successful people tend to wear a work uniform in inverted commerce, not necessarily a suit, but it may be a T-shirt and jeans. as we've seen with Mark Zuckerberg, who wears the same items every day to allow this freeing up of cognitive capacity for more important issues. And then, you know, for you or me, this might mean going to a meeting wearing something that we've worn before and knowing that it's suitable or it's appropriate and we don't have to worry about that at that time. I know there have been positive
嗯，如果我们穿的衣服让我们感觉不舒服，那会让我们感到压力。如果我们真的很担心它是否得体、是否合适，或者我们对所穿的衣服没有信心，这会让我们感到压力。这意味着我们没有认知能力来处理手头的问题。这就是为什么许多非常成功的人倾向于穿“工作制服”（加引号），不一定是西装，但可能是T恤和牛仔裤。正如我们看到的马克·扎克伯格，他每天穿同样的衣服，以释放认知能力去处理更重要的问题。然后，你知道，对于你或我来说，这可能意味着去开会时穿我们以前穿过的衣服，知道它是合适的，我们当时就不必担心这个问题了。我知道已经有了积极的
steps in the right direction, but it still seems like everywhere we go, bombarded with images that encourage us to consume fashion and that there's no way to escape it. How does that impact people's mental health? Well, people generally buy far more than they need. And probably, to be honest, none of us probably needs to buy any more clothes ever. Research suggests that 80% of clothes in our wardrobe is unworn. And that's quite worrying, actually. And some people can become addicted to shopping and this can result in debt, in shame,
朝着正确方向的步骤，但似乎无论我们走到哪里，都被鼓励我们消费时尚的图像所轰炸，而且无法逃避。这对人们的心理健康有什么影响？嗯，人们通常买的远比他们需要的要多。老实说，可能我们谁都不需要再买任何衣服了。研究表明，我们衣柜里80%的衣服是没穿过的。这实际上相当令人担忧。有些人可能会对购物上瘾，这可能导致债务、羞耻，
and guilt. And there's a move now to buy mindfully, which we've discussed. And I would definitely agree with that. Buying too much is something that we really should avoid. When you buy less, it seems like a win-win situation. You've got more money in your pocket to enjoy the experiences that bring more and lasting satisfaction. And you're also doing less harm to the environment.
和内疚。现在有一种趋势是理性购买，我们已经讨论过了。我绝对同意这一点。买太多是我们真的应该避免的。当你买得少时，这似乎是一个双赢的局面。你口袋里有更多的钱去享受那些带来更多、更持久满足感的体验。而且你对环境造成的伤害也更小。
So throughout this interview, you've mentioned several times about the importance of people being mindful of their purchases. And this move toward mindfulness is certainly wonderful in many ways. But how does that work within the fashion industry? Because they certainly need to generate profits. I mean, they want to respond to their customers in terms of wanting to be understanding and receptive to being more mindful about fashion. But at the same time, they also need to make money.
所以在整个采访过程中，您多次提到人们对购买行为保持正念的重要性。这种向正念的转变在许多方面当然是极好的。但这在时尚产业内部是如何运作的呢？因为他们当然需要创造利润。我的意思是，他们想在想要理解和乐于接受对时尚更加正念方面回应他们的客户。但与此同时，他们也需要赚钱。
So what are you seeing in terms of that tension that exists? Well, I think once the fashion industry is more in tune with what their customers want, actually want rather than what they think they want, when they're more able to predict more accurately, so production on demand rather than full supply, then, you know, this affects profits more so than the selling. So so much money is wasted on overproduction. So if that comes out of the equation, the company can still be profitable. You mentioned in your book, pressure to produce for consumers is so high that people in the fashion industry often suffer from mental health issues like substance abuse, anxiety, depression and eating disorders.
那么您在那种存在的张力方面看到了什么？嗯，我认为一旦时尚产业与客户真正想要的东西（而不是他们认为客户想要的东西）更加协调，当他们能够更准确地预测时，即按需生产而不是全量供应，那么，这比销售更能影响利润。所以太多的钱浪费在过度生产上了。如果这从等式中剔除，公司仍然可以盈利。您在书中提到，为消费者生产的压力如此之大，以至于时尚产业的人们经常遭受心理健康问题，如药物滥用、焦虑、抑郁和饮食失调。
So what needs to change in the industry? And are you seeing any movement in that direction, in a better direction? Well, I think we're still waiting for some change in that. And the cycles of fashion have become shorter and shorter. So where they used to be two seasons and perhaps a cruise collection, there are now six, seven, ten. Some high street brands have new stock every week, some every two weeks. And the designers are just on a treadmill. And the ones who we've seen are the very famous high-end designers where it makes news when they have mental health problems or worse. But there's a whole industry behind them of designers. assistants and interns who don't make that publicity when they have mental health problems.
那么行业需要改变什么？您是否看到朝着更好方向发展的迹象？嗯，我认为我们仍在等待这方面的改变。时尚周期变得越来越短。以前有两个季节，也许还有一个度假系列，现在有六个、七个、十个。一些高街品牌每周都有新货，有些每两周就有。设计师们就像在跑步机上一样。我们看到的是那些非常著名的高端设计师，当他们出现心理健康问题或更糟的情况时，这会成为新闻。但在他们背后，还有一整个设计师、助理和实习生的行业，当他们出现心理健康问题时，并没有得到那种宣传。
And it's not, there isn't time to speak out about how you feel. There isn't that possibility really. And it's not just the designers, it's models as well who, when there's a fashion week or on shoots, they have to be available from the designers. the early morning to late at night, looking fantastic the whole time, often no time to eat or very little time to eat, no food available for them. And there are reports of models saying that they've not been treated very well at all, that they're just treated like a clothes hanger, I suppose. You know, and they're not called by their names. Not all. And we see
而且没有时间去说出你的感受。真的没有那种可能性。不仅是设计师，模特也是如此，当有时尚周或拍摄时，他们必须随时待命，从清晨到深夜，全程看起来光彩照人，往往没有时间吃饭或很少有时间吃饭，没有食物提供给他们。有报道称模特们说他们根本没有得到很好的对待，我想他们只是被当作衣架。你知道，他们甚至不被叫名字。并非全部。我们看到
the very famous ones, the ones who have fantastic lifestyles. But again, there are thousands of models who don't enjoy that kind of celebrity status whose mental health may well suffer. And it may be that the fashion industry attracts people who are susceptible to mental health problems because it's so creative, so dynamic, so exciting. And the pressures are on, not just to work, but to be on form 24-7. And on the flip side, for consumers who see images of these impossibly thin and beautiful models, what does that do to a person's self-image and their positive feelings about themselves? Well, there's quite a lot of research now, which shows that even a very brief look at fashion imagery of thin models or airbrush models can damage a person's body satisfaction.
那些非常出名的人，那些拥有梦幻般生活方式的人。但同样，有成千上万的模特没有享受那种名流地位，他们的心理健康很可能受到损害。时尚产业可能吸引了那些容易出现心理健康问题的人，因为它太有创意、太动态、太令人兴奋了。压力不仅在于工作，还在于24小时全天候保持最佳状态。另一方面，对于看到这些瘦得不可思议且美丽的模特图像的消费者来说，这对一个人的自我形象和对自己积极的感觉有什么影响？嗯，现在有很多研究表明，即使是短暂地看一眼瘦模特或修图模特的时尚图像，也会损害一个人的身体满意度。
So they feel worse about their body than they did before after a very brief exposure. And given that we're exposed to images of fashion thousands of times in a week, you know, this is affecting most of us. And social media has a lot to answer for, to be honest, with the images that are on Instagram, for example, so anyone who likes fashion is going to be following the people, the designers they like, the models they like, the influences they like on Instagram.
所以他们在短暂接触后，对自己身体的感觉比以前更差了。鉴于我们每周成千上万次地接触时尚图像，这正在影响我们大多数人。老实说，社交媒体有很多责任，比如Instagram上的图像，所以任何喜欢时尚的人都会在Instagram上关注他们喜欢的人、设计师、模特、网红。
And most of them have a particular image, which the individuals want to aspire to. They aspire to it, but quite often are unattainable. And what do you think needs to change in this area? Well, same as it across the whole industry. More diversity, more representation. So not just on the other side of the camera, but in front of the camera.
他们中的大多数人都有一个特定的形象，个人想要向往。他们向往它，但往往是无法达到的。您认为在这个领域需要改变什么？嗯，和整个行业一样。更多的多样性，更多的代表性。所以不仅是在摄像机后面，而是在摄像机前面。
so more diversity in the workforce of the fashion industry and in the peripheral workforce, so model agents and so on. So far more representation of the populations that the fashion industry serves. And this isn't just about skin tone. It's about body type, body shape, ages, ability. I just the whole range, you know, as I said, right at the start, everyone wears clothes. And everyone should be represented by the fashion industry. Where do you see psychologists fitting into all this in terms of helping promote more inclusivity and diversity?
所以时尚产业的劳动力和外围劳动力（如模特经纪人等）需要更多的多样性。所以要更多地代表时尚产业所服务的群体。这不仅仅是关于肤色。这是关于体型、身体形状、年龄、能力。正如我一开始所说，每个人都穿衣服。每个人都应该被时尚产业所代表。您认为心理学家在帮助促进更多的包容性和多样性方面如何发挥作用？
Psychologists can run studies that test hypothesis that say that improving representation is good for the industry, good for the consumer and show the evidence, bring the evidence to the fashion industries. Psychologists can also help with the communities who are marginalized. And when psychologists work in the industry, they can actually really show the industry and how beneficial it is to have a diverse workforce. I mean, there's plenty of evidence for that already. Yeah, absolutely. And turning to a more casual topic, what are your thoughts today?
心理学家可以进行研究，测试那些认为提高代表性对行业有益、对消费者有益的假设，并展示证据，将证据带给时尚产业。心理学家还可以帮助那些被边缘化的群体。当心理学家在行业内工作时，他们可以真正向行业展示拥有多元化劳动力的益处。我的意思是，这方面已经有大量的证据了。是的，绝对是。转到一个更轻松的话题，您今天怎么看
about people dressing more casually. I mean, a lot of people wear active wear as everyday clothing and offices are becoming more casual in a lot of instances. Yeah, I'm fine with that. I, you know, in London, you can wear absolutely anything you want and nobody looks at all. I think it's great that people can wear whatever they want,
关于人们穿得更随意？我的意思是，很多人把运动装当作日常服装，在很多情况下，办公室也变得越来越随意。是的，我对此没意见。我，你知道，在伦敦，你可以穿任何你想穿的衣服，没人会看。我觉得人们可以穿任何他们想穿的衣服真是太好了，
whether that's active wear, casual wear to work. I think it's a really positive move. For lots of people working in a formal suit doesn't represent their true cells or their self-identity. And so they might struggle to do the kind of job that they want to if they were free to choose what clothes they can wear. Me, for example, I really don't like wearing suits and I would typically wear jeans. I'm wearing jeans now. jeans and a jumper or jeans and a shirt. So, yeah, I just think people should be allowed to dress in the way they want because the way we dress is part of our identity, part of who we are.
无论是运动装还是工作时的休闲装。我认为这是一个非常积极的举措。对于许多人来说，穿正式西装并不能代表他们真实的自我或自我认同。因此，如果他们可以自由选择穿什么衣服，他们可能会在做他们想要的工作时感到挣扎。以我为例，我真的不喜欢穿西装，我通常会穿牛仔裤。我现在就穿着牛仔裤。牛仔裤和套头衫，或者牛仔裤和衬衫。所以，是的，我只是认为人们应该被允许以他们想要的方式着装，因为我们的着装方式是我们身份的一部分，是我们的一部分。
Yeah, so what you're saying is a more casual environment overall does help people's mental health, I imagine, because if they're becoming more of an show expressing their authentic self as opposed to wearing a suit or uniform every day, probably feeling better, yeah. Exactly. They have the freedom to choose and autonomy, again, plenty of evidence to support this, giving people autonomy at work or in their lives in whichever aspects is possible is a really positive element of people's life. So people say often dress for success, does that hold water these days? It depends on the industry. Progressive industries, success might be a pair of jeans and a course. T-shirt with a slogan or something. Still in finance, it might be that you still have to wear a suit. When people ask me this question, I would always say, do some homework, find out what the next
是的，所以您的意思是，一个更随意的环境总体上确实有助于人们的心理健康，我想，因为如果他们表现出更多真实的自我，而不是每天穿西装或制服，可能会感觉更好，是的。正是如此。他们有选择的自由和自主权，同样，有大量的证据支持这一点，在工作或生活中尽可能地给予人们自主权是人们生活中一个非常积极的因素。所以人们常说“为成功而着装”，这在今天还站得住脚吗？这取决于行业。在进步的行业中，成功可能是一条牛仔裤和一件印有口号的T恤之类的东西。在金融领域，可能仍然需要穿西装。当人们问我这个问题时，我总是会说，做点功课，找出层级中下一级的人在穿什么。那份工作的潜规则是什么？因为，你知道，如果某样东西是不合适的，或者被可能雇佣你的人认为是不合适的，那么无论你多么喜欢它，它展示了你的身份，雇佣者可能会认为你并不是那份工作的合适人选。在我看来，这不应该有关系，但它确实有。作为一名时尚心理学家，您是如何对待您的衣柜的？我喜欢非常朴素、休闲的衣服。我尽量为我要去的场合穿得得体，是的，我会说我不想要那种会“尖叫”的衣服，
level in the hierarchy is wearing. What is the unwritten rule for that job? Because, you know, if something is inappropriate or just considered not suitable by the person who might be hiring you, then however much you love it, it shows your identity. The person, the hireer, might believe that you're not really the right person for that job. In my opinion, it shouldn't matter, but it still does. As a fashion psychologist, how do you approach your wardrobe? I like very plain, casual clothes. I try to dress appropriately for a situation that I'm going to yeah I would say that I don't want clothes that shout
所以我更喜欢那些本身不表达太多的衣服，所以我不是一个喜欢穿带Logo衣服的人，是的，通常是相当朴素的衣服，通常是黑色或海军蓝，夏天可能是白色，我是一个穿衣相当朴素的人。你知道，我实际上注意到一些最大的时尚设计师，你知道，他们会出现在T台上，穿着非常简单，可能是黑色的衣服。那么他们这样做有什么心理原因吗？他们是在试图把重点放在他们设计的其他衣服上吗？是的，我认为这几乎是时尚产业的一条潜规则，就是黑色。
so I prefer clothes that don't say very much about them so I'm not a logo wearer yeah typically quite plain clothes often black or navy in the summer maybe white I'm quite plain dresser. You know, I've actually noticed that some of the biggest fashion designers, you know, they'll come out on the catwalk and they're wearing very simple, maybe black clothing. So is there any psychological reason why they might do that? Are they trying to have the emphasis beyond the clothes of their other clothes they're designing? Yeah, it's almost an unwritten rule, I think, of the fashion industry is black.
几乎就像一种谦逊的着装，相当宽松、流畅、性别中性的衣服。是的，这在行业中已经存在很长一段时间了。是的，我想这因人而异。我的意思是，有些时尚设计师穿得相当，嗯，离谱，我们这么说吧。但是的，大多数人我会说只是朴素，也许是的，正如你所说，为了不分散人们对他们在T台上创作的作品的注意力。这总是让我觉得很有趣，一个人创造了这种近乎动态的服装，也许它是彩色的或什么的，然后出来时他们穿着可能是黑裤子和黑衬衫、运动鞋之类的，这总是
almost like a modest dressing, quite loose, fluid, gender fluid clothes. Yeah, and that's been around for quite a while in the industry. Yeah, I suppose it varies. I mean, there are some fashion designers who dress quite, well, outrageously, let's say. but yeah the majority I would say just plainly perhaps yes as you say to not distract from the creations they've made that are on the catwalk it's always kind of struck me as is interesting someone who creates this like nearly dynamic outfit maybe it's colorful or something and then comes out and they're wearing maybe a black pants and a black shirt sneakers or something like that's always
是的，哦，这有点刺耳，是的，没错。我想回到您提到的关于工作制服以及您可能在硅谷等地看到的趋势，即企业家穿休闲装，也许他们每天穿同样的东西，诸如此类。这背后有什么吗？您提到人们想要保留认知资源，但还有其他原因吗？有没有什么心理原因让某人想要穿一种自我强加的制服？它对他们正在互动的人传达了一些信息，例如，如果他们每天穿同样的东西，就不会有关于他们衣服的任何评论。所以，你知道，关于“哇，引起对他们所穿衣服的注意”这个问题，如果你每天穿同样的东西，就不会发生。也许这就是为什么时尚设计师和从事时尚工作的人穿很多黑色宽松衣服的原因，因为这并没有说明他们穿的衣服有什么特别之处。但我认为关于认知资源有一个重要的部分，因为如果你对你穿什么感到压力，或者如果你在想你穿什么，你就没有能力完全专注于手头的工作。你知道，担心它是否合适，或者我是否为这次会议穿得正确，然后我要去参加另一个会议。所以我认为工作制服可以节省早上的时间。
yeah oh it's a little jarring yeah right I wanted to go back with which you mentioned about the workplace uniform and kind of the trend you might see like in the Silicon Valley or something where entrepreneurs wear casual clothes, maybe they wear the same thing every day, that kind of thing. Is there any thing behind that? You mentioned people wanting to reserve cognitive resources, but is there any other, are there any psychological reasons why someone might want to wear a self-imposed uniform? It says something to the people who they are interacting with, for example, there's not going to be any commentary around their clothes if they wear the same thing every day. So, you know, this issue with, oh, wow, drawing attention to what they're
你不必做关于每天穿什么的决定。但这在工作中也非常有效，因为你不会得到关于你穿什么的评论。我认为人们会说“你每天穿同样的东西”的情况很少见。您认为时尚产业对心理学家有很多空缺吗？您提到想让更多人进入这个领域，但您认为这是一个您看到未来会增长的研究领域吗？对于心理学家或有心理学背景或对心理学感兴趣的人来说，是否有机会找到一种方法来利用他们的知识，在也许他们意想不到的不同领域？绝对是。
wearing just won't happen if you wear the same thing every day. And perhaps that's why fashion designers and people who work in fashion wear a lot of black loose clothing because it doesn't say anything much about what they're wearing. But I think there's an important part about the cognitive resources because if you're stressed about what you're wearing or if you're thinking about what you're wearing, you don't have the capacity to think fully on the job at hand. You know, worrying is it appropriate or have I dressed correctly for this meeting and then I'm going to another meeting. So I think a work uniform frees up time in the morning.
我认为今年对时尚零售来说是非常有趣的一年。我认为许多零售商今年会因为不断增长的消费者需求、不断加剧的竞争和全渠道购物的兴起而挣扎。所以心理学家突然成为了时尚产业中必要的人才，就像技术人员一样，去理解大脑中发生的所有过程以及人与人之间发生的所有社会过程。所以消费者、时尚员工和那些与时尚品牌合作但实际上不是品牌一部分的外围人员。我认为一个巨大的机会将会出现。
You don't have to make decisions about what to wear for the day. but it's also very efficient at work because you won't get comments on what you're wearing. I think it's rare that people would say, well, you're wearing the same thing every day. And do you think there's a lot of openings in the fashion industry for psychologists? You mentioned wanting to get more people in the field, but do you think this is an area of study that you see growing in the future and opportunities for psychologists or people, background in psychology or interest in psychology to find a way to use their knowledge, in perhaps a different field that they expected? Absolutely.
这需要时间。所以课程直到2014年才开始招生，但我会说在几年内，时尚产业对心理学家的需求将会很大。我真的觉得很重要的一点是，在时尚产业作为心理学家工作的人必须有心理学培训，而不能仅仅因为他们是人，就觉得他们是心理学家。我认为这真的、真的非常重要，因为心理学家也受过伦理方面的培训，理解，你知道，人是脆弱的，因为这个或那个原因做出声明可能会适得其反，对于那些无法处理某种结果的人来说，例如。所以我真的很在意有些人想作为心理学家在时尚产业工作，但他们对心理学几乎没有理解或培训。关于您刚才提到的伦理问题，最近像Gucci和Prada这样的品牌出现了一些丑闻，他们在种族和文化敏感性问题上存在问题。那么心理学家如何能在这方面帮助品牌呢？嗯，心理学家可以提供帮助，因为他们需要帮助品牌变得更加多元化。在设计、思维、沟通方面，因为这是一个缺乏多样性的问题，就像它是一个伦理问题和一个种族主义问题一样。所以这些品牌缺乏意识显然是令人震惊的。开展多样性项目、隐性偏见培训以克服人们所持有的偏见，以及让人们在实地真正与这些品牌所服务的社区合作。这不仅仅是冒犯，我认为品牌在做了冒犯的事情时必须举手承认。这一切都归结为多样性，但伦理是全面的，它需要隐含在品牌所做的一切事情中。所以，你知道，我们看到随着更多数据的使用，其伦理问题必须被非常认真地考虑。从您的角度来看，时尚产业的未来是什么？嗯，我认为时尚产业将会多元化，不仅仅是在劳动力或形象方面，而是在产品方面，在服务方面。因为如果我们真的要少买，而它仍然需要盈利。它需要以某种方式做到这一点。我认为时尚产业也将需要与其他学科合作。它已经在与人工智能和技术合作。它将与材料科学家合作得更多，创造可生物降解的纺织品，这些纺织品可以容易地编织、洗涤和护理，而且也将被编织，可以以一种不损害环境的方式回收。
I think this year is a very interesting year for fashion retail. I think a lot of retailers will struggle this year with the rising consumer demands and the rising competition and the rise of omnichannel shopping. And so psychologists are suddenly being the the people as well as tech people who are necessary in the fashion industry to understand all the processes that happen in the brain as well as all the social processes that happen between people. So consumers, fashion employees and the peripheral people who work with fashion brands but are not actually part of the brands. And I think a huge opening will happen.
时尚产业当然会与更多的心理学家、人类学家合作。我认为它将成为一个在过去非常基于设计和商业的行业，它将看到必要性，就像神经科学一样，与许多不同的学科合作，并真正欣赏行业内学科多样性的价值，这将使它变得更加丰富。非常感谢您加入我们，梅耶博士。我非常感谢您的时间。非常感谢邀请我。要了解更多关于梅耶博士的工作，请访问 www.psychology.
This takes time. So the course of only started recruiting in 2014, but I would say in a couple of years' time, there's going to be great demand for psychologists working in the fashion industry. And I really feel it's important that people who work in the fashion industry as psychologists have psychology training and don't just feel that because they're human, that they are psychologists. I think this is really, really important because psychologists are also trained in. in ethics and understanding that, you know, people are vulnerable and sort of making claims about what happens because this or that can backfire with people who are not able to
我们想知道您对我们节目的看法。您可以将您的评论和想法通过电子邮件发送给我，地址是 K-Luna@APA.org。那是 K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-Rg。《心理学谈话》是美国心理学会播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他很棒的播客，例如关于新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》和关于心理学实践的《进度记录》。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
handle the outcomes of something, for example. So I'm really conscious of some people wanting to work in the fashion industry as psychologists who have little or no understanding or training of psychology. And going off what you just mentioned about ethics, there's been some scandals from recent brands like Gucci and Prada who've had issues with race and cultural sensitivity issues. So how can psychologists contribute to helping brands in this manner? Well, psychologists can help because they need to help brands become more diverse. in the areas of design, in their thinking, in their communications, because this is an issue
例如处理某些事情的结果。所以我非常在意有些人想以心理学家的身份在时尚界工作，但他们对心理学几乎没有了解或受过相关培训。结合你刚才提到的道德问题，古驰（Gucci）和普拉达（Prada）等近期品牌出现了一些丑闻，涉及种族和文化敏感性问题。那么，心理学家如何能在这方面帮助品牌呢？嗯，心理学家可以提供帮助，因为他们需要协助品牌在设计、思维和沟通领域变得更加多元化，因为这不仅是一个道德和种族问题，也是一个缺乏多元化的问题。
of lack of diversity as much as it's an ethical issue and a racist issue. So the lack of awareness by these brands is clearly shocking. And running diversity programs, implicit bias training to overcome the biases that that people have and also getting people on the ground actually working with the communities who these brands serve. It's beyond offensive and I think the brands have to hold their hands up when they've done something that is offensive. It all comes down to diversity, but the ethics is across the board and it needs to be implicit in everything that a brand does. So, you know, we're seeing with more data use, the ethics of that
这同样是一个缺乏多元化的问题。这些品牌缺乏意识显然令人震惊。开展多元化项目、进行内隐偏见培训以克服人们固有的偏见，并让员工深入到这些品牌所服务的社区中去实际工作，这些都至关重要。这不仅仅是冒犯，我认为品牌在做出冒犯行为时必须勇于承担责任。这一切都归结为多元化，但道德是全方位的，它需要隐含在品牌所做的一切事情中。所以，你知道，随着数据使用的增加，我们看到其道德问题
has to be really seriously considered. From your perspective, what is the future of the fashion industry? Well, I think the fashion industry is going to diversify, not in terms of it, only in terms of its workforce or its imagery, but in terms of its products, in terms of its services. Because if we really are going to to be buying less and it still needs to make a profit. It needs to do that somehow. I think the fashion industry is also going to need to work with other disciplines. It's already working with AI and tech. It'll be working far more with material scientists creating biodegradable textiles that can be woven easily and laundered and cared for, but also going to be woven, can be recycled in a way that doesn't harm the environment.
必须得到非常严肃的考虑。从你的角度来看，时尚产业的未来是什么？嗯，我认为时尚产业将会多元化，不仅仅是在员工队伍或形象方面，而是在产品和服务方面。因为如果我们真的要减少购买，而行业仍需盈利，它就必须以某种方式实现这一点。我认为时尚产业还需要与其他学科合作。它已经在与人工智能和科技领域合作。它将更多地与材料科学家合作，创造出易于编织、洗涤和护理的可生物降解纺织品，同时这些纺织品在回收时也不会对环境造成危害。
The fashion industry will, of course, be working with more psychologists, anthropologists. I think it's going to be an industry that in the past has been very much design-based and business-based that will see the necessity, like neuroscience, for working with lots of different disciplines and actually appreciating the value of. of the diversity of disciplines within that, within the industry that's going to make it far richer. Thank you so much for joining us, Dr. Mayor. I really appreciate your time. Thank you very much for having me. To learn more about Dr. Mayor's work, visit www.psychology.
时尚产业当然会与更多的心理学家和人类学家合作。我认为，过去以设计和商业为导向的行业，将会像神经科学一样，认识到与许多不同学科合作的必要性，并真正欣赏行业内学科多元化的价值，这将使它变得更加丰富。非常感谢您加入我们，梅耶博士。非常感谢您的时间。非常感谢您的邀请。要了解更多关于梅耶博士的工作，请访问 www.psychology。
We want to know what you think about our show. You can email me your comments and ideas at K-Luna at APA.org. That's K-L-U-N-A-A-A-P-A-Rg. Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts such as APA journals dialogue about new psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find all our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website speakingofpsychology.org to listen to more episodes. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们想知道您对我们节目的看法。您可以将您的评论和想法通过电子邮件发送给我，地址是 K-Luna@APA.org。即 K-L-U-N-A@A-P-A.org。《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）是美国心理学会（APA）播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，例如讨论最新心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》（APA Journals Dialogue）和关于心理学实践的《进度笔记》（Progress Notes）。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到我们所有的节目。您也可以访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 收听更多剧集。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。